Okay, can we go ahead and get started? Welcome, everyone.
This is the Targeted Therapies Mini Symposium. I'm Claudia Benavente.
I'm an associate professor in the Department of Pharmaceutical Sciences at the
University of California, Irvine, and my co-chair today
is Ryan Potts, who is the vice president and head of Induce Proximity
Platform at Amgen.
And these are our disclosures.
So over the last two decades, targeted therapy has
transformed the practice of oncology.
What began with kinase inhibitors has evolved into a broad and
increasingly sophisticated effort to precisely intervene
in the molecular dependencies that sustain cancer.
And yet, despite these advances, we continue to face three central
challenges. First, oncogenic drivers remain difficult to drug,
particularly transcription factors and RAS family members.
Second, resistance is inevitable, often emerging through
pathway rewiring or adapted signaling.
And third, many cancers depend not on single proteins, but on
dynamic multi-protein complexes and cellular states that are not easily
addressed with traditional inhibitors.
So these challenges have catalyzed a major evolution in how we think
about targeting cancer.
What we will see in this session is a shift in strategy
from direct inhibition to pathway exploitation,
from single targets to coordinated system-level disruption,
from canonical drug targets to target RNA, protein complexes, and
immune regulators, and from passive delivery to tumor-selective uptick
mechanisms.
The talks today highlight three major emerging
paradigms in targeted therapy.
One, exploiting the tumor-specific biology for drug delivery and targeting,
targeting the undruggable through non-canonical modalities, and
leveraging the ubiquitin system and immune modulation.
So across these diverse approaches, a unifying concept
emerges
where we're no longer limited to inhibiting oncogenic proteins.
We can now redirect cellular machinery, exploit tumor-specific
biology, and engineer entirely new therapeutic modalities.
This represents this transition from targeting what is druggable to
targeting what is biologically essential.
With that, we have an exciting lineup of speakers who will take us through
these innovations from macropinocytosis-enabled delivery
to RNA-targeted therapeutics, to next-generation degraders and immune
modulators, and finally, pan-KRAS inhibition strategy.
So let's begin with our first speaker, Jinhua Hu, who will
introduce CQ0736 and a new
paradigm on targeting KRAS-driven cancers.
Good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
This is Jinhua Hu from CentaliCon Pharmaceutical.
It is my pleasure to introduce-
Use the microphone.
To
introduce our project,
CQ0736, a new polysaccharide-based
therapeutic modality, targets PAN-KRAS tumors with
robust anti-tumor activity with macropinocytosis.
Globally, 20% of cancer patients carry RAS
mutations, including KRAS, NRAS, HRAS.
Significant recent advances include
S6236 and adagrasib.
Major challenges for current RAS targeted therapy include
limited response rate, limited durability, and acquired
resistant treatment-related toxicity.
To overcome these challenges, we develop a new therapeutic
strategy.
Left side, tumor targeting mechanism.
We know that target delivery is very important.
We achieve target delivery with two layers.
First, we achieve tumor tissue targeting with EPR
effect. Second, we achieve tumor cell targeting with
macropinocytosis.
Macropinocytosis is an endocytosis mechanism.
To support their rapid proliferation, certain tumor cells
actively take up nutrients such as polysaccharide and
proteins from their surroundings through macropinocytosis,
a process that is tightly regulated and maintained at low basal
level in normal cells, but continuously activated
in tumor cells.
RAS-driven tumors enhance macropinocytosis.
Broad coverage and reduced resistance achieved by targeting this
fundamental metabolic vulnerability rather than a
specific surface receptor.
Our Trojan horse approach. We engineered
CQ0736, a dextran-based conjugate
covalently grafted with docetaxel and
gamma-linolenic acid.
The field of polysaccharide drug conjugation has long been impeded by
significant technical bottlenecks.
We are the first to apply click chemistry, a Nobel
Prize-winning technology, to polysaccharide drug conjugation,
and successfully develop CQ0736.
This reaction is high specific,
delivering a super yield, exceptional purity, and high
drug loading,
creatively transform a complex chemical
problem into a scalable, industry viable manufacture
processThis is a
chemical structure and the mechanism of action.
Dextran is the carrier for targeted delivery.
Docetaxel is a payload to induce apoptosis and
kill tumor.
Gamma-linolenic acid synergistic enhance tumor
targeted delivery and the tumor killing of DTX.
It also reduce P-glycoprotein expression and
inhibit P-gp mediated efflux.
Glutamic acid functionalize dextran,
developing a negatively charged conjugate.
This stealth approach minimize immune recognition and
RES clearance,
dramatically reduce uptake by normal cells.
0736 demonstrate a potent inhibitory activity in
pancreas tumor cells.
This table shows 0736 significantly inhibit a
panel of KRAS cancer cells in vitro.
Unique biodistribution. Left top, for
0736, free DTX levels in tumors demonstrate
sustained intratumoral delivery over 96 hours.
Left bottom,
for 0736, free DTX levels demonstrate
preferential accumulation in tumor tissues compared
with normal tissues at 24 hours post-dose.
Right top, dextran-GLA-Cy 70.5 achieve
tumor selective accumulation via macropinocytosis.
Last one, dextran-GLA-Cy 70.5 achieve
superior tumor to normal tissue contrast with
macropinocytosis.
0736 significantly inhibit tumor growth
in KRAS G12C CDX model.
In KRAS G12C lung cancer CDX model, this
blue line, 0736 administered
once weekly.
Green line, RMC administered once daily.
0736 shows superior antitumor efficacy.
At day 28, its tumor volume is
3.6-fold lower than RMC and
5.2-fold lower than adagrasib.
Less resistance was observed in 0736.
Delayed resistance observed in RMC.
Rapid resistance observed in adagrasib.
No body weight loss was observed in
0736.
Similar result were obtained from another KRAS G12C
lung cancer CDX model and a KRAS G12C
PDAC CDX model.
0736 significantly inhibit tumor growth in
KRAS G12D CDX model and a KRAS
wild type CDX model.
0736 demonstrate durable antitumor activity
in
PDX model.
KRAS G12C lung cancer PDX models.
At day 49, 0736 tumor volume is
16.54 lower than RMC.
Resistance was observed in RMC, while CQ
0736 maintained a durable tumor control without
resistance.
No significant body weight loss observed.
Similar result were obtained in KRAS wild type lung cancer PDX
model.
Safety profile.
0736 demonstrate an improved hematology, hepatic,
and renal safety profile compared to parent DTX.
H&E stain.
0736 demonstrate potent antitumor activity with minimal
system toxicity.
Summary.
CQ 0736 represent a new targeted
therapeutic strategy for PANKRAS-driven cancers,
leveraging the combined mechanism of macropinocytosis and
EPR effect.
Robust antitumor efficacy was demonstrated across
KRAS G12C, KRAS G12D, and KRAS wild type.
No acquired resistance observed during treatment.
Well-tolerated with no body weight loss.
CQ 0736 establish a potential first-in-class
glyco-targeted delivery modality with scalable and
expandable into a broader glyco-DTx platform,
fundamentally unlocks the potential of polysaccharide-based
therapeutics.
Conclusion. CQ 0736 demonstrate
clinical relevant efficacy, improved safety profile,
and a strong translational potential supporting advancement
toward R&D enable study.
Right side, the polysaccharide can link with drug and the targeting
ligand simultaneously.
Thanks to our team members, thanks to Medici company,
thanks to our session chair, and thanks to everyone.
Now we open to questions.
Hi. How is the compound administered in vivo? How is it administered?
How do you give it? How do you dose the compound?
Um.
Is it intravenous?
IV, right?
IV, yeah.
Yeah. And what is the half-life? How long
does it
circulate for?
Half-life is
four times of the parent drug.
Four times of the docetaxel. Four times
of the parent drug.
And what is that in hours?
I can ask our scientists to send you the exact
information.
Thank you.
But you can see that our
0736 administered once weekly.
Once weekly.
But IMC administered once daily.
So our half-life is
very good.
Hi, thanks. What is the distribution of components of this?
It looks like it would probably be a fairly heterogeneous mixture.
So how do you characterize that, and how would you plan to control that going
forward?
Can you explain?
He's asking about the drug product and how you make a homogeneous
mixture of this polysaccharide drug.
So our starting drug, the dextran, is the
GMP level, and we use the
click chemistry. This is a high specific
reaction, so the
product is with
super purity up to 95% and
super reaction rate up to 90.
So you show that the drug has less resistance
compared to the rest. Could you please explain?
Do you know why-
Yes
... there's no resistance showing up?
Oh, yes, because our 0736 is
targeting a fundamental metabolic vulnerability.
It's not targeting a specific surface receptor.
This is first reason. The second reason, by
internalizing the
nanostructure rather than small molecule,
so it's
hard for the P-gp to expel.
And the third reason is that
we link the gamma-linolenic acid
to the
dextran. This GLA
can stop the
P-gp expression and
reduce its expel. So our
high accumulation can
prevent the drug resistance.
Maybe I can ask a couple questions too.
I'm really interested in this concept that you have
increased uptake in
specific sort of genetic lineages due to upregulation of the
macropinocytosis process.
Do you know the relative sort of uptake
rates or
ratios if you compare a KRAS mutant versus wild
type on how much increased macropinocytosis is happening?
Oh, about five to 10 times.
Five to 10 times. Okay. When
I think about the comparison to what you're building here,
maybe the most direct comparison is to a ADC,
because obviously there you're doing targeted delivery, and it's through a sort
of
IV type dosing.
How do you think about the comparison to this polysaccharide
conjugate versus an antibody conjugate?
How do you think those will be sort of differentiated?
So antibody conjugate
will
trigger the immune
system, but
for
our 0736,
we link the glutamic acid.
This make
the conjugate negatively
charged, so it is
stealth from the immune system and
cannot be
found by the immune system. So this is first
reason
it's better than ADC. ADC is
positively charged, so it's easy to
attract with the normal cells, is ADC has
more
side effect toxicity.
It's
not distributed as good as our 0736.
And
also ADC has shown drug
resistance.
Maybe finally,
what about anti-drug antibodies?
Do you
have any information on how these polysaccharide delivery
mechanisms, whether they would be subject to
anti-drug antibodies?
Yes. So
we will not trigger anti-drug
problem.
Because
we are hide from the
immune system, so we will not cause the
anti-drug problem.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, moving on now to the next presenter, who
will be Michelle Kriner from Wayfinder
Biosciences, who's going to talk about a potent orally bioavailable small
molecules that inhibit c-MYC translation and suppress tumor
growth in vivo.
Yeah. Hi. Thank you to the organizers for this opportunity,
and I have no disclosures.
So I'm really happy to be here today to introduce you to Wayfinder
Biosciences and our approach for going after
undruggable protein targets by targeting the
mRNAs that encode them.
So specifically, we are developing orally available small
molecules that can bind to regulatory RNA
elements and disrupt their function such that the
undruggable protein target is not produced in the first place.
And the way that we find these molecules is based on a
technology that was developed by our co-founders during and
after their PhDs at the University of Washington in
Seattle. And this technology enables us to convert
RNA structure modulation into an easily readable fluorescent
signal.
And so essentially what we're able to do is isolate
RNA structures of interest from a target mRNA,
encode them into our Wayfinder platform, and screen small
molecule libraries against these RNA targets to
identify molecules that are able to bind to our
target of interest and stabilize its structure in a manner that is
selective for that RNA over other RNA targets.
And so for the proof of concept of this platform, we
wanted to go after a very high-value undruggable target.
And so obviously MYC really rose to the top of that list, and that's what
I'm going to present to you today.
So MYC should need no introduction to this audience.
It is arguably the most important undruggable protein left in cancer,
and there's a massive opportunity to impact patients in
diverse indications.
But unfortunately, there has been a lot of failure in this space because MYC
really does have the perfect storm of undruggable properties.
So as a transcription factor,
its protein structure is quite disordered and there's no catalytic
pocket to target.
In addition, biologics can't access the protein because it's in the
nucleus.
And MYC is very important for the proliferation of healthy
cells and is also very rarely mutated in cancer,
making it very difficult to develop selective targeted therapies.
And so at Wayfinder, we believe that targeting the mRNA of
MYC can address these issues with drugging the
protein. And in addition, we have
discovered a mechanism
whereby targeting a regulatory circuit that's only used under certain
conditions in cells can actually give us a way to selectively target
tumor cells over healthy cells.
So the way that we began this program was inspired by the literature.
So there have been reports of an IRE-like element in the MYC 5'
UTR, whereby RNA structures can regulate translation of
the MYC open reading frame under stress conditions.
And so we chose three RNA motifs within this 5'
UTR region
and encoded them into our Wayfinder sensors
and screened these against a library of 50,000
diverse drug-like small molecules.
And through this effort, we were able to identify four
unrelated compounds that were able to
significantly reduce c-MYC protein levels in a highly MYC-amplified
mesothelioma cell line.
And from these, we chose to proceed with
WDC-198 for optimization.
So we set up a hit-to-lead screening funnel,
whereby analogs of WDC-198 were first
tested for their ability to bind to our MYC mRNA target in our
Wayfinder sensor assay,
followed by assessing their ability to repress MYC protein
levels through an HTRF assay,
and also looking at their cellular potency by CTG assay.
Importantly, we did see very good correlation between these
three characteristics throughout the series, which is really important.
In the RNA space, we don't really have the benefit of structure-guided drug
discovery and development. So we're really doing this the old-fashioned way.
And so our initial compound, WDC-198, had
a cellular potency of about one micromolar.
And over the course of eight months and about 200 compounds, we were
able to improve the potency over one hundredfold
to yield this compound, WDC-623, that has
single-digit nanomolar potency.
And this is the compound that we have now moved into in vivo studies.
So WDC-623 and other compounds related to it are
quite potent in multiple solid tumor types.
So we are hoping that we will have broad applicability in many types of
solid tumors.
Importantly, if cells do not express the MYC mRNA,
our series is much, much less potent.
So here I'm showing some data we collected with an earlier compound in the series
where we tested its potency in NCI-H1836
cells, which are an L-MYC amplified SCLC, and compared that
to our workhorse cell line, NCI-H82, which is a c-MYC
amplified SCLC. And we saw
a greater than hundredfold difference in potency between these two cell lines, and
our compound also did not reduce L-MYC protein levels in
H1836
cells.So our compound
acts very rapidly. Within 30 minutes, we see
significant reduction of Myc protein levels, and this is
consistent with our proposed mechanism of inhibiting translation
initiation, followed by normal turnover of the Myc protein, which has
about a 30-minute half-life.
Importantly, we do not see the same effect for other short half-life proteins,
such as RPL15, shown here.
The effect of our compound is fully reversible upon compound washout,
and we do not affect levels of the Myc mRNA
transcript in these cells, which is also consistent with a
translational mechanism.
So we were really excited to look at the proteome-wide effects of our compound and
see that repression of cMyc is the dominant effect.
So this is an experiment where we treated NCI-H82 cells
for two hours with our compound at 20 nanomolar.
And we see that by label-free mass spec, we
detected about 9,000 proteins with high confidence.
And of those, cMyc and its direct transcriptional targets,
CDC25A and B, were the most strongly repressed proteins.
So this is really exciting validation of the selectivity of our
compounds.
So as we move towards in vivo studies, we needed to look at
the ADME and PK properties of our compounds.
Our original hit, WDC198, had pretty
good ADME properties to start with.
Very soluble, lipophilic, et cetera, but
it was very unstable in the liver. And so this was an area that
we needed to improve.
We did identify a structural liability that we were able to
correct and improve the stability of these compounds.
And so with WDC623, we are able to get
sufficient exposure to accommodate twice-daily
dosing of our compound,
although we still do have more work to do on the PK.
But we thought that this was good enough to at least try a proof of concept
experiment in vivo.
So we did a CDX study with the NCI-H82 small cell
lung cancer model, and we were really excited to see that five mgs per
kg twice daily dosing,
oral dosing,
gave us statistically significant inhibition of tumor growth.
And importantly, we did not see any body weight loss or clinical
observations during this study. So this was really the first proof
that our
compounds and our mechanism are functional and tolerable in vivo.
So I mentioned at the beginning that potency is really not enough when it
comes to Myc. We really need selective ways
to only target Myc in the cancer cells and try not to hit
the healthy cells that also depend on Myc.
And so we think we have a way that we can address this with our
compounds.
So pretty early in the development, we noticed that the activity of our
compounds was somewhat media dependent,
and we were able to isolate a single nutrient
that was responsible for this effect.
And so I'm showing a western blot here, where in every lane, the cells were
treated with the same concentration of our compound,
but we're titrating the levels of this single nutrient.
And at high levels of the nutrient, which do correspond to normal blood levels of
the nutrient,
our compound is essentially inactive at repressing Myc levels.
But if we reduce the nutrient levels to levels that are similar to that
found in solid tumor microenvironments,
our compound becomes very active against Myc.
And so we are hoping that we can set up a system where we
can deliver these compounds orally, and that
in nutrient-rich normal tissues, they will not affect
Myc in normal cells. But in nutrient-poor environments, such
as solid tumors, cMyc will be downregulated and the cancer cells will
die.
And so in order to sort of test this idea
for our next in vivo study, we wanted to look at a
model that was poorly vascularized to really emphasize
the nutrient depletion in solid tumors.
And we also wanted to look in large tumors
because we thought that would be a nutrient-limited environment as well.
And also that's a much more realistic and difficult environment for testing
therapeutics.
So we did a study in the MiaPaCa2
model of PDAC.
And in this study, we did not dose until all of the tumors had
reached 600 cubic millimeters or larger.
And we were super excited to see in this study that we saw tumor
regression with an average of 125% TGI.
And again, importantly, there was no clin obs or weight loss observed during this
study.
So we think that this is a really exciting result that we're going to
follow up on as soon as we can, and hopefully we'll get even better
as we improve the PK properties of our compound.
We also did look in the blood of the mice from the PDAC study,
and we see no evidence of anemia, thrombocytopenia, or
bone marrow dysfunction.
We do see a little bit of lymphopenia,
but this has been a major challenge in the field of Myc-targeting therapies.
And so we think this is
at least a good hint that we are sparing normal cells and really
focusing on targeting the tumor cells.
So with that, I will thank our investors and our funding sources.
Our SAB members as well have developed many small molecule drugs
previously, so they've been great to help us for doing this our first time.
Special shout out to Nick Terret, who is our medicinal chemist.
And this is the team at our lab in Seattle.
Thank you, and I'm happy to take any questions.
All right. Thank you, Michelle. Use the microphones if you have questions, please.
Hi. Maybe I missed it. There was something regarding the
deregulation of MYC within two hours from the first
administration. Sorry, treatment of cells, I think that was-
Yeah.
But you also showed some MYC targets at two hours.
So I was just wondering how quickly that can happen.
Are those MYC targets also
short-lived? Because you are looking at protein levels, I assume.
Yeah. So I showed CDC25A and B, which
are short half-life proteins.
Yeah, so the other MYC targets, I think, tend to have longer half-lives.
We haven't looked at any time points shorter than two hours by proteomics.
Okay. Thank you.
Over here.
Is the site in the mouse MYC RNA 100% the
same as in the human MYC RNA? Because that clearly
would impact the safety data that you showed.
Yeah, that's a great question.
And not identical, then your safety data may be not
entirely-
Yeah. So I didn't have time to show the data.
We have looked at the effect of our compound in mouse cells,
and our compounds are able to... They are active
in mouse cells. The sequence of the 5' UTR is
not 100% conserved,
but we do repress MYC in those cells.
Over here.
Hi. Great talk.
I guess most of us in the business in small molecules are interested in
protein binders,
and completely ignore whether compounds are binding to RNA,
perhaps at our peril. But are you guys also looking at how your
compound binds to proteins? Probably is also happening to some degree, or
are they completely different structural classes that are new and-
Yeah. So the library we screened is
a typical diversity library. We don't think there's anything different about the
chemistry. We haven't looked for direct binding
to specific proteins, but we definitely do think there could be a
protein involved in our binding pocket.
It might not just be
a small molecule RNA interaction.
It could also be an RBP involved in the regulation.
So we're working on that now.
Okay, thanks.
Over here. Yeah.
Hi. The
tumor growth inhibition, the xenograft models were quite short. They were 14 days.
Mm-hmm.
But why so short?
Yeah. In the SCLC study, we had to start sacrificing
the vehicle mice after that
time.
Because they were too bad, right? Okay.
Yeah.
Did you continue with the treatment group, the compound treated?
No, we terminated them. Yeah.
All right. We have two quick questions. Final over here.
Very nice talk.
As soon as you target cMYC, you're going to have a reactivation with nMYC or lMYC.
Mm-hmm.
Are you planning to also take your strategy and develop inhibitors
to cMYC and MYC and lMYC? I guess you'll have to have one for each.
Yeah, that's a great question. It would be a different screening campaign at
that point because the UTRs are not conserved across the paralogs.
But yeah, that is certainly something we want to keep an eye on.
Yeah. Did you perform any dose-limiting toxicity studies?
And what has been dose-limiting
toxicity? Another comment before you answer that,
I just want to say this is a chemistry small molecule
session, and you never show the structure.
I'm not sure what the
issue is, and we need to know the physical chemical attributes of
this candidate.
Yeah. We hope to be able to disclose that soon.
We have looked at high doses in mice, and
we do see some acute toxicity that we think is driven by a
spike in c-Max,
so we're trying to optimize that out now.
Okay. Thank you, Michelle.
Our next speaker is Frederick Cohen from Nurix Therapeutics,
who is going to be talking about the discovery and characterization of Cbl-B
intramolecular glue inhibitors that increase T cell activation and suppress tumor
growth.
Yes. Thank you. Thank you for the invitation to speak here.
Thank you all for coming. It's a real honor to speak
on behalf of a very large team at Nurix that worked over many years
to generate the data that I'm about to show you
today.
These are my disclosures.
Nurix is a public company. These are the company disclosures.
If you're having trouble sleeping, you can go to our website and read these at your
leisure. Today, I'm going to talk to you about Cbl-B,
which is an E3 ubiquitin ligase that is highly expressed
in immune cells and serves as sort of a master regulator of immune
cell activation.
Blocking Cbl-B removes a brake on the immune system,
and Cbl-B deficient mice demonstrate robust T cell
and NK cell mediated tumor immunity, anti-tumor
immunity.
These are some of the data that got us interested, and the field in general,
interested in Cbl as a target for immuno-oncology.
So some time ago in 2011, Paulino and coworkers generated
lines of mice that
have
an inactive Cbl knock in or Cbl, oops, excuse me, or
Cbl knocked out.
And then when T cells were isolated from these mice and stimulated
either with
signal one alone or signal one and signal two, we can see that there's a
significant increase in IL-2 as a measure of T
cell activation.
And that increase is equivalent
in both the inactive knock in and the ligase
knockoutNurix
generated our own line of mice with a different
inactivating mutation. And with
that line, we were able to reproduce the previously
demonstrated
tumor rejection phenotype.
So taken together, these data indicate that
pharmacological inhibition of CIBL B should be sufficient
to initiate immuno-oncology or
immune-mediated tumor rejection.
And again, as a reminder, this is immuno-oncology, so these are wild-type mice
bearing mouse-derived tumors, and we are sort of releasing
a brake on the immune system to reject that tumor.
So CIBL B is an interesting protein in that through
its regulatory mechanism.
In its inactive state, it's folded up on
itself and is incapable of binding a
ubiquitin-loaded E2 ligase.
But the tyrosine kinase binding domain contains an SH2
domain that when it binds to a phospho substrate, pushes it
into an open conformation that can then be phosphorylated
on a particular tyrosine 363, thus locking
it in the open conformation and allowing a
ubiquitin-loaded E2 to bind for subsequent
ubiquitination and degradation of substrates.
So with this understanding of the regulatory
mechanism, we were able to design assays for high-throughput screening
to look for inhibitors of CIBL B.
The first assay that I'm going to describe today is what we call the phospho-CIBL
assay. So this assay was charged with
closed state inactive CIBL B
tagged with a fluorophore through streptavidin.
And then we added a ZAP70 peptide and Src kinase
and ATP.
Excuse me.
And in this case, Src kinase does double duty.
It first phosphorylates the ZAP70 peptide, which then serves as the substrate
peptide, pushing CIBL into the open conformation, which can
then be further phosphorylated by Src kinase.
And then detection is through FRET with an anti-phosphotyrosine antibody.
Now, of course, this assay will also discover Src kinase inhibitors,
so in every well, we had
a parallel screen for just ZAP70
peptide phosphorylation,
so that we could weed out kinase inhibitors from our assay.
We also had an orthogonal E2 binding assay as
a further measure of validation. And in this case, we switched
the FRET partners. We put the terbium on the streptavidin,
and this time had a fluorescently labeled
E2-loaded ubiquitin ligase, so we could look for FRET sort of in the other
direction. It helps us weed out artifacts.
So with these assays, we screened a small library
of 250,000 compounds at a single point
concentration, 10 micromolar.
And hits were defined as any compound that inhibited more than 20%
of CIBL activity and less than 20% of Src
kinase activity.
That's shown here in the yellow box.
From this assay, we got 1,100
hits, which were manually filtered for
properties and diversity. PAINS were removed, things like that.
A few of those were not available for dose response, so that
limits us down to 90.
The ones that did provide dose responses were then further in the
biochemical assays were quantified by SPR,
and those were filtered by sensogram shape and fit.
We really like SPR for validating hits because it gives you a really nice measure
of compound specificity and stoichiometry.
And that afforded one compound that was then progressed to
crystallography, and this is the structure of that compound,
NRX-001.
So as you can see, it has a potency of about 30 micromolar in the
biochemical assays, does not inhibit Src
peptide phosphorylation, and has a very nice SPR
sensogram showing one-to-one stoichiometry.
This compound was racemic in our library, so we proceeded to resolve it into its
two enantiomers. And we were gratified to find that all of the activity
resides in one of the two enantiomers.
Again, this is another measure of specific binding to the target.
And those data are shown here. No activity for the wrong enantiomer, and all of the
activity is in the S enantiomer.
So crystallography revealed the binding mode of this compound, and
it binds to
a pocket that's sort of at the center of the closed state conformation,
where the three domains of the protein come together.
So this is tyrosine 363. That's the
critical tyrosine that gets phosphorylated in the open state.
And this molecule forms a nice pi stack with that tyrosine, as well
as
several important hydrogen bonds in the triazoles.
One is water-mediated to a backbone
of this helix over here, and then another direct hydrogen bond to another
tyrosine on the other side of the pocket.
Additionally, we form a third hydrogen bond with a backbone
NH and a couple of hydrophobic interactions on the
aryl part of the molecule over here.
And if you put a surface on this structure, we can see that the ligand is almost
completely buried in the pocket,
which makes it a very nice starting point.
So with all of this information in hand, the medicinal chemistry
team-- Oh, sorry, excuse me. Back up one step.
So what is this molecule actually doing?It binds
to the closed state at the interface of all three of the domains, the
ring, the linker helix, and the tyrosine kinase binding
domain. And it glues it shut, basically, preventing it
from opening into the active state.
And so with this, we call this an intramolecular glue inhibitor, and it's
very reminiscent of how the SHP2 inhibitors also work.
So Med Chem team got to work. We were very quickly able
to leverage this structural information provided by
the crystal structure and optimize
both the affinity and the properties simultaneously.
So what you can see is that if we extend the hydrophobic group a little bit with
a CF3 or cyclopropyl, we pick up improved interactions with the lysine
that's right there, the hydrophobic part of the lysine.
Removing the sulfur from this linker dramatically increases the
metabolic stability.
And then finally, getting rid of the chiral center with this oxetane allows us to
pick up another water-mediated hydrogen bond in the back pocket for an
additional increase in potency.
And as a measure of compound properties here, I've shown the lipophilic ligand
efficiency, which is sort of a
power-to-weight ratio of how well you're using the grease that's on your
molecule. And what you can see is that through careful optimization, we were
actually able to increase this significantly as the optimization went along.
So this, NRX-8766, was the first molecule that
we thought had the proper potency and pharmacokinetic properties
to test in a mouse model.
So here again on the left is the data I showed before, the genetic phenotype.
And when 8766 is dosed in mice in the same
CT26... Actually, sorry, this is a different model.
This is the CT26 engineered model.
This is TC1. What you can see, though, is that we do reproduce the genetic
phenotype of tumor growth inhibition.
However, you can see these doses are pretty high.
And so we thought we had significantly more medicinal chemistry to do to get a
drug. And unfortunately, due to time today, I have to summarize
several years' worth of work with one slide,
showing that over the course of optimization, we
were able to even further increase the potency and the lipophilic ligand
efficiency at the same time. And I'm really proud of the team in this work, because
a lot of times these plots go the other way.
You have to start adding grease into your molecule to make them more
potent. So this is NX-1607. I'm getting short of time.
This is NX-1607. It's very potent.
Kd is sub-nanomolar.
It's very potent
in supporting the activation of
T cells in response to stimuli. So the molecule doesn't do anything to T
cells by itself, and that's illustrated here,
showing what happens if you treat the cells with just compound.
And then when you add stimulation, you get whopping increases in both interferon
gamma and IL-2.
And this molecule now shows robust efficacy
at significantly lower doses. So now we're down to 10 or 30 mgs per
kg per day in mouse models, and we see
robust efficacy in
colorectal cancer, triple-negative breast cancer, and a B cell
lymphoma model, single agent.
Of course, in immuno-oncology, you always want to know how you're going to do with
anti-PD-1. So NX-1607 strongly
synergizes with anti-PD-1 to enhance survival, again, in
multiple tumor models.
Further characterization of NX-1607 is displayed here.
We have
a very potent Kd of 0.4 nanomolar, driven by a slow off rate.
I
won't go through all these parameters, but it's a very nice drug, Class 1, highly
permeable, highly soluble, good oral bioavailability across
species, except for rat. Rat was a bit of an outlier, but this still didn't
prevent us from using rat as a toxicology species for this molecule.
And NX-1607 has advanced into Phase 1 clinical
trials, where we see
dose-dependent pharmacokinetics
and increase in phospho-HS1, which is a proximal
biomarker of Cbl-B activity. So we're seeing
increases in this biomarker into the region where we
see efficacy in mice, and that data has been presented in other
posters from Merrick. So I invite you to go to our website and look up
that data.
So
in summary,
is our deep understanding of the regulatory mechanism of Cbl-B allowed us to
design mechanism-agnostic screening assays that would pick up
inhibitors of any step of the activation of Cbl-B?
High-throughput screening and careful follow-up afforded a singleton hit
that
glues the molecule, the Cbl-B protein, into a closed conformation,
preventing its activation.
Optimization resulted in NX-1607, which is a potent and selective inhibitor
of Cbl-B that has advanced into Phase 1 clinical trials
and shows linear PK and modulation of proximal
biomarkers.
Thank you very much.
Any questions?
Hi.
Hey, Brad.
Hi, Gina.
Great talk.
Thank you.
Very amazing to see from a library size of
250K molecule, eventually triaging down to
one real hit.
Yep.
I'm curious about the design of the
library.Structure diverse
focused, or is it E3 ligase focused?
It's a diversity library from one of the major vendors that did
the screen for us. We went to a CRO that has high-throughput screening
capability in their own library.
So it's not purely designed just for E3 ligase.
No. It's just a diversity library.
Excellent. Thank you.
For your clinical trial,
how is the drug formulated?
I don't think we've revealed that yet. So I can't answer that. Thanks. Sorry.
Yeah, Judy.
Hey, Fred. Very nice talk. I was wondering, so you showed in
the original hit that you had an euchroemic ratio of
almost perfect. So one enantiomer was more active than the other one?
Yes.
But that was also the center that you quaternarized, and it was still even more
potent. So can you understand why?
Yes.
So the wrong enantiomer of that particular compound is
in a conformation that can't
bind. But if you make it symmetrical, now it can adjust a little
bit and still bind. And because that oxygen's there,
in that particular marker, we can pick up an additional
water-mediated hydrogen bond in the pocket that's right behind
the inhibitor.
Okay, one last question.
So as you probably know, there is a lot of excitement about
finding new E3 ligases for PROTACs.
Yes.
And your target is an E3 ligase.
So I have to wonder, did you come across
any implications that this could also be
a PROTAC, a partner here?
Well,
it would be interesting to be able to harness SIBL as a PROTAC.
The problem with this particular series that I'm showing you here is that it binds
to the inactive state, so it wouldn't be effective as
a ligase part of a PROTAC.
If you could bind to the active state, the open phosphorylated
active state, then you might be able to do something with it.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Okay, moving right along. Our next talk is going to be from Jennifer
Griffin from Neomorph, who will give us some more
information about something we heard earlier in the conference, Discovery and
Optimization of NEO811, a first-in-class molecular gluer degrader
of ARNT.
Okay. Awesome. Thank you for the introduction, and I'm really excited to be here
today to share a little bit more about some of the work we've been doing at
Neomorph.
Neomorph is a molecular glue-focused biotech company here in San Diego.
Here are my disclosures.
So at Neomorph, we're interested in targeted protein degradation, and in
particular, we're interested in developing molecular glues.
And molecular glues differ from PROTACs or heterobifunctional degraders in that
they're typically smaller, much more drug-like in property
space, and really importantly, they don't rely on the presence of a ligand binding
site on the protein of interest. And so this allows access to a
much broader portion of the proteome.
And so at Neomorph, we're interested in developing molecular glues to target some
of these classically undruggable disease-driving proteins in
oncology and as well as other therapeutic areas.
So one of the proteins that we identified as a potential target for a
molecular glue degrader is ARNT or HIF1 beta.
And this protein is a transcription factor, so it's a classically undruggable
target, classically unligandable, and so we thought that it would be really
amenable to a molecular glue approach.
ARNT is a clinically validated central node in cancer biology.
It has a clear link to disease. In clear cell renal cell carcinoma,
VHL is inactivated, which leads to
over-stabilization of HIF2 alpha and HIF1 alpha.
ARNT is an obligate binding partner for these two proteins, and these heterodimers
regulate transcription of genes for angiogenesis like VEGF, as
well as other tumorgenic drivers.
ARNT also binds to and regulates AhR,
and suppresses anti-tumor immune responses.
And so in the clinic,
and approved drugs are
available that target different arms of this pathway.
Most notably or most recently, HIF2 alpha inhibition,
including Belzutifan
by Merck, which inhibits HIF2 alpha.
There are also VEGF inhibitors and, of course, immune checkpoint
inhibitors. And so we envision that targeting ARNT would really provide a
complementary approach to these existing standards of care,
but also have potentially broader efficacy as a single agent,
as it operates through this pan-HIF inhibition mechanism.
And so when we set out to identify molecular glue degraders, we took a
multi-pronged approach. We assessed for
cellular degradation in our screening platform.
We also looked for formation of ternary complexes using
our internally developed DEL screening platform.
And we also assessed our chemical library in an unbiased format by
looking at whole cell proteomics.
And from these different approaches, we were able to identify multiple different
starting points for ARNT degraders.
We were eager to establish early on the mechanism of action
for these small molecules degraders we identified, and in particular, try
to determine whether or not they were indeed operating through a molecular glue
mechanism where they mediated a direct interaction between, in this
case, our target protein ARNT and an E3 ligase,
allowing the target protein to be ubiquitinated and degraded by the proteasome.
And so I'm showing here one representative hit compound, compound A, and we
observed that this compound degraded ARNT in a cellular context in a
dose-dependent manner.And then really importantly, we observed that
degrading ARNT led to inhibition of HIF transcription.
Both of these phenotypes were rescued with knockout of the E3
ligase cereblon, which supported E3 ligase dependency.
We were also able to quickly determine a ternary complex structure,
and this ternary complex structure supported that ARNT and
cereblon directly interact,
and that interaction is mediated by a small molecule, molecular glue.
And something that was really interesting about this ternary complex structure was
that ARNT actually undergoes a really significant conformational change during
recruitment, wherein multiple domains of ARNT come together to interact
with this new interface of cereblon.
We were able to confirm this direct interaction through subsequent
mutagenesis studies, where we observed that a single amino acid
mutation on the degron of ARNT or the portion of ARNT that interacts directly with
cereblon led to
mitigation of the ternary complex formation.
We also saw that mutations at these two different interacting
domains of ARNT led to disruption in formation of the ternary
complex.
We recapitulated this in a cellular context, where you can see
that with these mutations, we no longer observed ARNT
degradation. So again, this was really exciting to the team, and to the best of our
knowledge, this was the first example of an induced
neo-substrate degron.
And so,
with this MOA, degradation MOA established, we initiated a hit
to lead chemistry campaign. And upon initial profiling
of our chemical matter, we observed that
our chemical series degraded not only ARNT, but also some of these common cereblon
neo-substrates. So the focus of the chemistry effort was really to
enhance the depth and potency of ARNT degradation, but also determine
strategies to dial out some of these off targets.
And it's commonly thought that
engineering selectivity into cereblon-based molecular glues is
really challenging or not possible.
But at Neomorph, we've developed expertise in
rationally designing both on-target potency as well as
off-target selectivity into our chemical matter.
And so in this case, from the ternary complex structure, we made
several observations that led us to develop some hypotheses about how we
could enhance affinity of our molecular glues to
ARNT as well as cereblon. And we were equipped with ternary
complex structures with some of our off targets, which provided additional insight
into how we may be able to offend their recruitment.
So one of these opportunities I'm showing here, we hypothesized that
if we could extend our ligand to fill this proximal pocket, that we
may be able to enhance ARNT degradation and improve our selectivity.
And so we took a series of different approaches, and the approach that
we ultimately found to be successful required conformational restriction of our
ligand to optimize positioning of a substituent into this region.
And when we did this, we arrived at what I'm showing here, is
compound B, although this was after multiple iterations of SAR.
And you can see here that this compound has a significant increase in the depth of
ARNT degradation, which was really exciting for the team.
We also were able to mitigate some of these off targets, including SALL4,
but you can see that ultimately we significantly enhanced the depth
of CK1alpha and Ikaros degradation.
And so at this point, looking at the data and the structure, we had some hypotheses
that perhaps attenuating the size and lipophilicity of this
substituent might be able to enhance the selectivity.
And we also thought that by modifying more distal portions of the molecule, we
could optimize the engagement in this region.
And so again, after some iterations of designs, we arrived
at compound C.
This compound is, again, a very robust and potent
degrader of ARNT.
And in this case, now you can see
significantly improved selectivity against these common cereblon neo-substrates.
And so we were really excited about the position we were in with this chemical
matter,
and we initiated a campaign to improve the physical chemical properties
as well as ADME properties of this chemical series.
So through that effort, we arrived at NEO811.
NEO811 is a very
potent and robust degrader of ARNT, and you can see that it does
so in a cereblon-dependent manner.
811 shows excellent selectivity against these common cereblon
neo-substrates. And then again, importantly, we demonstrate potent
disruption of the HIF transcriptional pathway.
And when we compare this to Belzutifan, which is an FDA-approved
HIF-2alpha inhibitor that's current standard of care for CCRCC, you
can see that we've achieved superior potency to this modality.
NEO811 shows favorable preclinical properties.
We saw excellent exposure in both rodent and non-rodent species,
and we were able to demonstrate significant tumor regression in
a CCRCC xenograft efficacy study in tumor-bearing
mice.
This compound was administered once daily for 21
days and was very well-tolerated.
And so in summary, I've been able to share with you today some of the
story of how we were able to discover NEO811, which is a
potent, selective, and first-in-class molecular glue degrader of
ARNT. Much of this effort was informed by the
ternary complex structure
and multiple structures that the team was able to
solve. And these structures provided insight into how we could
rationally design improvements in both our on-target depth of degradation and
potency, as well as improve the selectivity profile of our chemical
matter.I think this story really highlights
the power of the molecular glue modality.
ARNT is considered to be classically undruggable, and targeting this node
of cancer biology and ccRCC may not be possible
without this
modality. And I think it really highlights how we can kind of redefine the
druggable landscape.
NEO811 is currently in a clinical trial for locally
advanced or metastatic non-resectable clear cell renal cell carcinoma,
and we're hopeful that this molecule will provide a meaningful new treatment
option for affected patients and their families.
So I'd like to acknowledge the Neomorph team.
This was absolutely a team effort.
And
most of the team is pictured here. This was, again, highly collaborative, and
I'm just here representing the work that so many other people did.
I'd like to thank the co-founders as well, and of course, our investors and
collaborators, without whom any of this science would be possible.
And of course, I'd like to thank you for your attention, and I'd be happy to take
any questions.
Nice.
Very nice story. Thank you. I have a similar question to Gina.
Is your DEL sort of loaded with cereblon binders,
looking for that?
Yeah. So our DEL, we have a multi-ligase platform at Neomorph,
so
we assess a variety of different ligases against our targets.
By DEL?
Yeah.
Through all our screening platforms, we have this multi-ligase platform, yeah.
Thank you.
Great talk. Thanks.
Did you look at all into the consequences for AHR or AHR signaling,
how this is affected by getting rid of ARNT?
Yeah, that's a really good question.
And we can disclose more about that at a later date, but I think you're pointing to
something that's really interesting about this mechanism that by targeting
ARNT, there's more than just the HIF-2 alpha pathway that we can modulate.
Okay. Other question. Is it a mixture of
diastereomers?
Yes.
You can see that one stereocenter is defined and the other is not. Mm-hmm.
Maybe I'll follow up with one question.
This structural rearrangement is,
as you pointed out, quite interesting.
And
I guess one might even predict that the ternary
complex could be inactivating
itself,
not necessarily requiring degradation to block activity given
the large structural rearrangement.
Just curious if you ever ran across any molecules that are strong
ternary complex producers that maybe not degrade but still inhibited
ARNT activity.
That's a really interesting question.
I can't speak to that in particular, but I think that's
something that is worth investigating more and considering.
Yeah. I'm curious about the ternary complex.
You mentioned that once the compound binds, the ARNT actually
rearrange induced fit. So when you optimize from
non-selected compound A to selected compound C, do you see
significant changes on the ARNT conformation during that
process?
We're going to be disclosing a lot more
about the structure at a later date,
but I think that this novel mode of recruitment has been largely
maintained across our different chemical matter.
Okay. If no more questions, thank you so much.
Thank you.
Okay. Our next speaker is
Rong Zeng
from Arizona State University, who's going to be talking about DNA templated
spatially controlled proteolysis targeting chimeras.
Okay.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for the opportunity to stand here on behalf our team and
to present this work from our lab.
I have no financial relationship to disclose.
So, I will start with the PROTAC. So everyone knows the
PROTAC actually is a hetero bifunctional molecule and
made by a chemical link
connected protein of interest ligand and E3 ligand spacer.
So, the PROTAC has been quite successful and powerful
and represents a new modality in cancer therapeutics.
But currently, a lot of the PROTAC efficacy
highly depends on the product delivery complex geometry
formation. So which means with the chemical
linker, normally it's
difficult to predict the
geometry and also how to tune the activity
systematically. So,
for that, we ask a very simple question, which is, what
if
degraded geometry were programmable?
So, for that question, our answer is we can
utilize the DNA. As we know, DNA is a program
materials. And even though the DNA has long time been
recognized the genetic materials, it carries the genetic information,
but actually, DNA is also being used as
structural materials as well. So it has a very well-characterized
structural properties, and it's a Watson-Crick base pair, make it highly
predictable and programmable self-assemble.
And they easily choose the 3D dimension in
space.I will show two brief examples for
this. So first, the image on the middle here,
the smile face and also the star.
These two shapes actually are made by DNA.
So simply, it just puts the DNA strand into the tube and put it in the
thermocycle and leave it several hours.
And when you come back, and it's formed this structure like this.
So it enables a very precise geometry control.
And another interesting for DNA is it's highly
biocompatible. So which means you can conjugate with
other biomolecules. And
also, as an example shown here, the enzymes conjugated
with the DNA and also spaced on the DNA
helix bundle structures with very precise seven nanometer space
between the enzymes for coordinating the enzyme
reactions.
So our lab, my PI, Professor Haoyan, has been working on the
DNA technology and its biomedical application for over 20 years.
And with that background and also all the foundations,
made us ask questions, which is, could we use DNA
structural programmability to control the geometry of the degraded
molecule?
So, this brings us to our hypothesis.
So traditionally, the PROTAC
requires a multiple-step synthesis
and has a very quite limited control on the 3D orientation.
And
one example is, if you want to make it multifunctional and
on the multi-target, actually require further synthetic
complexity. So,
we propose that we actually can
label the ligand on the single-strand DNA
and on the separated strand, and through hybridization of DNA,
and to make the PROTAC-like molecules.
So it also is a bivalent, but the difference is we use the DNA as
the molecular linker here. And slowly rotate the DNA,
and we place the ligand on different spots of the DNA.
And the DNA has very well-characterized structural properties.
So you can control the distance, and you can control the orientation.
You know between the anchor point, what is the angle, what is
the distance, very precisely. And more interesting, if you want to
make it multifunctional or multi-targets, we don't need to
resynthesize this. We just drop the different molecular function
as DNA strand together and anneal it.
And for example, we can make these three-arm
junctions just by putting the three sequences together.
So, we start this project with a 20
base pair double-strand DNA. Why we choose this?
There are a couple of reasons. First, this length is within the
FDA-approved nucleic acid therapeutics.
siRNA, antisense oligonucleotides close to this length.
And also, to improve the stability, we functionalize the
phosphoramide bond on the terminal DNA duplex.
And also involves the internal dBi modification to further
click the ligand on it.
So next, we move to the target selections.
So the target we select here is CDK4/6 Cyclin D1
complex. Why we choose this target?
Actually, there's three major reasons we select this target.
First, obviously, this target is quite important, it's
oncoprotein targets. It controls the cell
cycle transition over activity in most type of the cancer.
And second, the Cyclin D1 is undruggable protein.
Third,
when we start this project, we actually found there's three
already published paper. They use exactly the same
ligand for CDK4/6 and third one, but just a
various different link, and they get the quite
different degradation prophecy.
But none of them able to induce the Cyclin D1 degradation.
So that's our interesting. The hypothesis that even
so we use the same ligand here, but by properly orientate the
ligand and orientation, there's a chance and a possibility also
induce the Cyclin D1 degradation.
Which means we actually, for this undruggable target, we use a
variable ligand to make a bridge and
induce the undruggable target degradation.
So we initiate this project by synthesis
of four type of version PROTAC, and
puts the ligand functionalized on the different spot.
And on the base pairing version one, and version two, and version
three, puts the ligand separately on the major groove and the minor groove of the
DNA, and also at the two end of the DNA duplex,
which then gives the largest distance.
So, we transferred this four version into
glioblastoma cell U251 with two concentration,
20 and 100 nanomolar, and do the initial screening.
As you can see, the image here is quite interesting, but just test the
four version. It actually gave us quite a differential degradation,
with the version one able to induce the CDK4, CDK6,
as well as the Cyclin D1 degradation.
And version two, more selective for CDK4 and the Cyclin D1.
And more interesting for version three, it's quite selective, only
induce a reduction of CDK4. While for the largest distance,
unable to induce any protein reductions.
So, to further understand the mechanism behind those differential
degradation, we perform the molecular dynamics simulation
analysis. So through the simulation analysis, the
results tell us for each of the version, at the
end, they cause the quite differential ternary complex
conformation change. As you'll-- version one has the
CDK4 and the third one more close, and the second version have the
CDK4 more close to third one. And the version with the
largest distance, unable to induce the stable ternary
complex.And also, as indicated,
the
free energy binding, ΔG, and with successful
degradation, three version one, two, three, all give the negative values,
which means they actually form the stable ternary complex.
So
we are more interested in cyclin D1 degradation.
And so that's why I refer the extra more on DTAG version
one.
There's obvious question here, whether the cyclin D1 degradation is
caused by the synchronous degradation or is caused by
secondary effect of the CDK4/6 degradation.
So to confirm this, and we further
conducted the time course and the dose course experiments.
Both experiments tell us these three protein
change synchronous. They start decrease at the same time point
from four hours and also at the same
concentration, 20 nanomolar. Even they showing have the different
IC50 values.
So
we also continue with the DTAG version one, conduct the
antitumor assay in vitro and the in vivo assays.
So here today, I just want to show the in vivo assay here.
For the in vivo assay, to make it a more systematic
comparison, we include all the possible control here.
Stalling, and the control is just a DNA depressor itself with the
PS modification and without ligand.
And the DNA depressor with ceruloplasmin ligand, and the DNA depressor with
CDK4/6 inhibitor, and as well as our DTAG version
one. And during the whole treatment process, DTAG
version one able to consistently shrink the
tumor growth compared to all the other groups.
And it showing the best robust antitumor activity compared to
other versions. And during the whole treatment
procedure, the mouse body doesn't alter a lot,
which indicates no severe side effect observed.
And also the tumor tissue staining tell us
the more necrosis, and it lowers the Ki467
expression.
So with those success, we move to expand
this platform. We want to know whether this platform is generalizable,
is versatile for other complex protein as well.
So one trick here is for any new targets, we don't need
resynthesis. We just need to put the inhibit, like
here is the CDK9 inhibit on the one strand, and while we can
keep the E3 ligase strand similar.
So we're able to get a new library for this new target.
Similarly, and we also make the library for CDK2 and cyclin E
through the screening, and we get the
successful degradation for CDK2 cyclin E complex, as well as
the cyclin T1 and CDK9 complex.
So with those success, currently our lab
focus on three major direction. First is the DNA barcode library to screen the
spatial factor of the degrader. Second is through
program the nucleic acid design that actually can make is
oncogenic trigger,
PROTAC, that's only work in the cancer
cell and bypass the normal cells. And also last,
and also most important is combined with the target delivery to enhance
the clinical translation of this platform.
At the end, I want to thank my advisor, Professor Hao Yan, and our
DTAG team, and also our lab members who make this work possible,
and our collaborators and the funding support.
Thank you so much. I'm happy to take any questions.
We're open to questions.
While we wait, I was kind of curious, do you foresee
that
through degrading cyclin D, that you'll be able to overcome resistance with
CDK4/6 inhibitors?
Huh?
Have you tried this on cell lines that are resistant to
CDK4/6 inhibitors?
Oh, yeah.
Does that-
They have trying
multiple other cell lines, and they currently are
constructing the drug-resistant cell line to try this. Yeah.
And,
sorry.
You're good.
Have you checked to see that the Rb levels are remaining constant
through?
Oh, Rb level?
Yeah.
So they also check the Rb level, and the phosphorylation of the Rb level
get decreased after treated with the DTAG version.
Total Rb is-
Yeah.
... it's constant.
All right.
So you've talked about the small molecule parts here,
but what about the DNA itself? How do you choose the
sequence here that you're using? And in particular,
of course, there is many DNA-binding molecules inside the cell.
How do you prevent off-target effects here?
Yeah.
Thank you for those questions. That is a good question.
So
initially, they choose the random sequence, and because
currently design is a sequence independent.
So they functionalize the molecule on the DNA backbone, not on the nucleotide.
And also, after that, we conduct this
proteinomics analysis to select where they have off-targets of a DNA
social protein. From our screen and also second validated
by Western blots, currently, they didn't observe very
obvious DNA social protein degradation, but
obviously we need a more deep study on that.
But they do check change to the different sequence, even the different
sequence length, change to the 15 nucleotides.
It doesn't change the degradation efficacy. Yeah.
Yeah, maybe I'll follow up with that question.
Yeah, it's really interesting-Curious
about
whether you're getting
recognition of these molecules
by the innate immune system, so activation of cGAS-STING, for
example.
We haven't conducted that experiment now, yeah.
But it is a good idea we should try.
Okay, and then sort of following up on the last question, one could imagine you
could take advantage
of-- Of course, in this case, you're just sort of using the DNA as a
scaffold.
Mm-hmm.
However,
if you were trying to degrade things that bind to DNA-
Yeah
... you could take advantage of the DNA as giving a little bit of a helping
boost for recruiting the target. I don't know if you
looked into that at all or not.
Yeah. Actually, we have another project, it's talking to degrade the DNA-binding
proteins. So, that works well. Yeah.
All right. One last quick question.
Yeah. Very nice work. Have you checked the selectivity over other
cyclins, like cyclin D3?
Yeah. So, we check also other CDK
family proteins, CDK one, two, three, nine, and the
results, I didn't show here, but it's included in our paper.
It doesn't degrade the other CDKs.
At least as a homologous CDK2, CDK4, and the 6.
I mean, cyclin D3 also is in con-
Yeah. D1, D2, D3, you mean?
Okay.
Yeah.
So is the degradation through binding to which
component?
Yeah.
To the whole complex or like a specific CDK?
Whole complex.
Yeah, so basically it is through binding to CDK4, 6-
Yeah.
And D.
And D1. Yeah.
Yeah. Those ones we want through use the CDK4/6 as a bridge.
And because cyclin D1 is undruggable, so there's no available inhibitor we can
use for make the PROTAC. So we target CDK4/6, and it's
by degrade the cyclin D1. Yeah.
Thanks. Thank you.
All right. Thank you so much.
Our next talk from Jin Cui from Blossom Hill Therapeutics,
who will tell about Discovery and Characterization of
BH-501284, a Non-covalent
Pan-KRAS Inhibitor for Treatment of Diverse
KRAS Mutant Tumors.
Thank you. Thanks to the committee for choosing our
abstract
and for this mini symposium. Today, we
will present discovery and the characterization
of BH-501284, a novel
non-covalent pan-KRAS inhibitor for treatment
of diverse KRAS mutant tumors.
Here is my disclosure.
KRAS mutations are the most abundant,
and frequent oncogenic mutation has been reported
in cancers. The covalent KRAS
G12C inhibitors have been approved in KRAS
G12C mutant non-small cell lung cancer and colon
cancer. The second generation, derazatinib,
has achieved further improved
efficacy in second-line KRAS G12C
mutant non-small cell lung cancer with objective response rate
56% and progression-free surviving time
of 14 months, which set the bar
for what could be possible KRAS
inhibition can achieve.
Now, many
discovery and also development program have focused
on KRAS mutations and beyond KRAS
G12C, with three major efforts,
and include the switch II pocket and the
inhibitors, triplex inhibitors, and also
degraders.
The pan-RAS inhibitor, deraxurase, has
demonstrated efficacy in non-small cell lung cancer
and also PDAC beyond KRAS G12C mutations,
but with greater adverse event in clinic.
The switch II pocket was first identified with
covalent KRAS G12C inhibitor.
The pocket is shallow, such that the
non-covalent inhibitors are often out of rule
of five drug space, requiring higher
molecular weight, leading to unfavorable oral
bioavailability.
MRTX1133 was the first
non-covalent molecule achieved a potent
cellular activity against KRAS G12D.
As you can see, the double basic centers
make MRTX1133 class of
KRAS G12D molecules with minimal
oral bioavailability.
The effort of replacing the basic hydro group
with neutral group or reducing overall
basicity significantly increased the molecular weight
as compared with traditional kinase
inhibitors. That will limit potential clinic
success.
Therefore, a fresh chemical scaffold beyond
MRTX1133 scaffold will be
needed
to deliver pan-KRAS switch II inhibitor
with both high potency and also potential
good efficacy in
clinic.What
is the best strategy to enable KRAS
switch 2 inhibitor success in clinic when
facing unfavorable
target pocket?
The switch 2 allosteric pocket is available
in both GTP-bound on and
GDP-bound off KRAS proteins, and
switch 2 inhibitors can achieve dual state
binding and induce a similar confirmation
in both on and off states.
The mechanism of switch 2 inhibitors
blocking KRAS signaling relies on
rigidification of the KRAS protein to be less
flexible for fitting the tight
interaction with effectors such as RAF
protein. Therefore, our design approach
is to design a novel switch 2 chemical
scaffold that can induce strong conformational
change, leading to high binding affinity and a
long resident time with a pseudo-irreversible
characteristic to effectively block KRAS
interactions with effectors.
Here is our lead compound,
BH501284,
also referred here as 1284.
In a nucleotide exchange assay,
1284 potently inhibits the cell swine
medium KRAS bound GDP to GTP
exchange for KRAS G12 mutations and
also wild type KRAS with good selectivity
over wild type HRAS and NRAS. In
SPR studies using GDP bound
KRAS G12D protein, 1284
demonstrated picomolar binding affinity with
more than 54-hour resident time.
That reflects a pseudo-irreversible binding
characteristic.
While AMG 410 was tenfold
less in binding affinity and shows
1.4 hour resident time in the same assay.
The long resident time for 1284 was
observed for both GDP bound and also
GTP bound KRAS protein.
We have compared our pseudo-irreversible
dual state pan-KRAS inhibitor,
BH501284, with KRAS
G12D tri-complex on inhibitor
zotaurapib in KRAS G12D mutant
GP2D cells.
1284 showed fast and complete
inhibition of active KRAS interaction with
RAF,
with sustained inhibition for phosphorylation in
washout experiment, while on inhibitor
zotaurapib showed incomplete and slow
inhibition kinetics and gradually
lost inhibition of phosphor ERK in washout experiment.
We have evaluated
BH501284 in many
KRAS mutant or amplified cell lines for
inhibition of phosphorylation of ERK and also in cell
viability assays. In 2D cell viability assays,
1284 had a medium IC50 of
0.73 nanomolar against KRAS
G12V mutant cells, 2.8
nanomolar against G12D, and 0.62
nanomolar against KRAS G12C mutant cells.
It is also potent against other G12 and
G13 mutations except G12R.
1284 is potent against cells with amplified
KRAS
with IC50 around 1.48
nanomolar. It is not active in NRAS and
HRAS mutant cells.
BH501284 demonstrated
dose-dependent increase in mouse oral PK
exposures at 5, 15, and 50 mg/kg
dose levels, and also achieved deep tumor
regression in KRAS G12V, G12D,
or G12C mutant mouse CDX tumor models,
even at 5 mg/kg BID dose level.
Here are six examples.
Our pseudo-irreversible dual state pan-KRAS
inhibitor,
BH501284,
has a prolonged inhibition of KRAS signaling,
as reflected in the washout experiment
and in KRAS G12C mutant
H358 cells. After 24
hour washout, 1284 sustained
inhibition of phosphor ERK as effectively
as a covalent KRAS G12C inhibitor, devorasi,
while AMG 410 lost the phosphor ERK
quickly.
The prolonged KRAS signal inhibition
enabled 1284 to achieve deep
tumor regression, even at a 5 mg/kg BID dose
level in H358 CDX tumor model,
whileWhich is comparable with covalent
inhibitor avarasib. While AMG
410 only achieved 59% tumor
growth inhibition even at 100 mg per
kg BID dose level.
Many pan KRAS switch 2 inhibitors are reported
to achieve tumor regression at a quite high dose level,
often use 100 mg per kg BID.
As shown here with two clinic compound in
H441 tumor model,
BH 501284 achieved a
deep tumor regression even at a 15 mg
per kg BID dose level in the same tumor model.
Upper regulation of EGFR signaling have been
recognized as a potential resistant mechanism of
KRAS inhibitors. We evaluate BH
501284 under the challenge of
EGF ligand and also in cellular assays.
Unlike AMG 410 in the assay, which
gradually lost the inhibition of phosphor ERK and
the challenge of EGF, 1284
achieved the sustained inhibition of phosphor ERK and have
only about twofold shift of IC50
in cell proliferation assay.
1284 demonstrate great synergy with
EGFR antibody cetuximab in long-term cell
growth assay.
Overall, BH
501284 is a potent
pseudo-irreversible dual state pan KRAS
inhibitor, sparing H and N RAS. In
addition, what I have presented,
1284 also demonstrate improved oral
bioavailability across species.
And the enabling studies are currently ongoing.
Thank you for your attention.
So
it has been suggested that the on state, off state of KRAS
inhibitors may have different therapeutic effects.
So with your approach then you'll be active and against both on
and off states of KRAS?
Yes, as we indicated, and the allosteric
pocket and exist in both on and off state.
The molecule and target the allosteric pocket and
is able to bind both state level. And
so it is very important to shut down very
effectively the cycling and from GTP to
GDP. And no matter on which state. So we think
it is very important to have the end
result and have the complete inhibition of the
KRAS and RAF interaction as we demonstrate. Yeah.
Go ahead.
Thank you. That was very interesting, and I'm wondering what pseudo-irreversible
means. So does it mean that there's a covalent, there's a
bond to the protein, and it can just come on and off, or you
just are binding so tightly that it
stays on for 54 hours or whatever?
Yes. Here we use a pseudo-irreversible reflak, and
it's very slow off rate. And of course, with a
strong induced conformation change, it also have the slow
on rates there. And we want to leverage the great
advantage with covalent KRAS G12C inhibitor as
demonstrated in clinic. And with this pseudo characteristic,
and we are able to achieve low dose level in
the animal study for the good
efficacy result.
Yes. I saw that, the top. Thank you.
Yeah.
But I'm wondering about the off rate.
What is the lifetime, rather, of KRAS?
So do you have a potential advantage that you bind really tightly but not
covalently so that you can have compounds sitting around when the
next round of KRAS gets made? Have you evaluated that
versus covalent inhibitors, which are going to go away when the
protein is degraded?
So this is also great question, and definitely, and this is also
regarding for dose level and based on the
PK/PD studies, and it determine the dose level and
also schedule. And then to cover and
the requirement in the target coverage there. Yeah. Mm-hmm.
Thank you. Mm-hmm.
Hi, Jean. Fantastic talk.
Yeah, and I think the question I originally have, you may have already
answered it, but I want to dig a little deeper.
So for the KRAS G12V model that you shared,
the molecule actually has tenfold lower dose than the
other two molecule compared. So other than the
quasi-irreversible nature of the molecule,
does the PK exposure also contributing to the lower
dose observed?
Yes, definitely. Also, we
present our PK exposure level, and so the
PK is also relatively in the good side, and
that is contribute. However, we have the tenfold
different. This is definitely also contribute from the
pharmacology benefit of the pseudo-irreversible
characteristic. Thank you. Mm-hmm.
Super quick, last question.
Yeah, so go ahead, but super quick.
With the pseudo-reversible then, do you still see activity with
compound washout?
Can you repeat the question?
With compound washout after compound washout?
Oh, yes. Yeah. We demonstrate two case examples.
One is for KRAS G12D. After washout, it's about
10%. And, for the very
sustained inhibition of the 90% of the
phospho-ERK is still there. We specifically compared our
molecule with covalent molecule side-by-side
regarding to the washout experiment and then demonstrate, and it
performed very similar compared to the devarasib. Yeah.
Similar to the covalent?
Yeah. Mm-hmm. Yeah.
So just following up on the kinetics question,
do you have similar kinetics for the on state?
You only show the SPR for the-
Yes. And, so with the space limitation, and so
we also have the similar and off rate.
And for the on state it's slightly short and I think
here it's more than fifty-four hour, and for the GTP
state. And for the GTP state, and it's about fifty-four hour.
Yeah. Mm-hmm. Thank you.
I'm just going to ask one last question because it's a question that's coming from
an online, so it's the last one. So based on the nucleotide exchange
assays showing only less than 10 times the wild
type KRAS selectivity over HRAS and NRAS,
do you think the more durable phospho-ERK expression could be
due to broader suppression across all RAS isoforms?
Yeah, this is a great question, and we didn't show the data.
We also have the screen to quite a panel and with
different mutation, not a KRAS mutation, not amplification.
For example, an EGFR mutation. We know the KRAS
pathway is activated by RGK mutation there.
The molecule shows no activity and such as a
PC9 activity is larger than three micromolar. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you, Jean.
Thank you.
Okay, so the last speaker of the session is Aihuan Yu
from DeepKinase Biotechnologies, presenting on
Proteomics in TBD: A Case Study Unveiling the Novel
Multimeric Degradation Mechanisms of TRIM21.
Good afternoon, everyone. My name is Aihuan Yu from
DeepKinase. Thanks for the organizers about the opportunity to speak today.
And my topic is about the proteinomics in TBD.
Okay. Studying, unveiling the multimeric degradation
of mechanism of TRIM21. And first, I will
introduce the background of TBD.
TBD can expand therapeutic strategy,
rather than just inhibit them. TBD have two main
modalities.
The PROTAC is biofunction. Molecules can bring
a substrate to the E3 ligase. And the molecular
glues can induce the proximity of the substrates and the
E3 ligase with a smaller compound.
However, this field is largely limited by a few E3
ligase. And in addition, it's also difficult to distinguish
the direct degradation with the indirect downstream
effects, and to resolve when and where the degradation
happens. So, this challenge motivates the need
for proteomics-based approaches.
And, in this study, I will break down how to
apply proteomics in the discovery.
And this study of finding the TRIM21
can base molecule glues and protect manners.
And first, I will introduce the proteomics used in
this study.
The global quantified proteomics can help define the
selectivity. And as the volcano plot shows, each dot
means quantified
proteins, with the x-axis shows
the fold change, and the y-axis shows the
statistic significance. So the left
proteins with high significance means it's
largely degradated, and it's clear to identify the
desired targets, unexpected target, and some off-target in a
balanced manner. And it also enables rapid
prioritization of degrader candidates.
Besides that,
integrated proteomics can help define the target's
engagement and function in TBD. And several
approaches
answers several different questions, such as
interaction proteomics, chemo proteomics, and
ubiquitin, and phospho-proteomics.
The picture shows the proximity labeling strategies.
First, the biotin fuse to the protein of interest,
and after treatment with BioID, the protein can be
biolized and treated with TBD.
So recruited
nearby to the proteins can be labeled and captured
and identified by mass
spectrometry. And this strategy help to
identify the context of degradation
in cells.
Let's back to the case study, and this
study start with phenotype screen.
And wild type cells labeled in GFP.
And the IFNGR1 deficient cells are labeled
by mCherry. The two populations of cell are mixed
together and treated with interferon gamma and a
large number of
compounds.If the compounds act through the
IFN pathway, it only affects wild type cells
and decreases the ratio of GFP to mCherry.
So as the right picture shows, if the compound shifts
the ratio left, which means it acts through the
IFN-dependent. And
so we find three ACE compounds that can
induce the IFN-dependent cell death.
But what is the underlying mechanism?
Genome-wide CRISPR screening performed to find the
genes required for ACE activity.
As the picture shows, the right genes with high
significance means their loss can rescue this
phenotype. Here comes several proteins about
IFN pathway-associated proteins.
However, here comes the TRIM21. TRIM21 is
E3 ligase, is originally known as
the innate immune sensor. It can
recognize the antibody-coated pathogens
in cells and induce its degradation.
So here comes the hypothesis that
ACE may trigger a TRIM21-mediated degradation.
And we also want to know what is degradated, and
when the degradation happens, and where the TRIM21 is recruited.
So we will use several different approaches to answer these
questions.
As the global proteomics shows, we can see in the
volcano plots, what stands out are several
nuclear pore complex proteins. And
this means the degradation is selectivity.
And after treatment with ACE, with BTZ, or
proteasome inhibitors, we can see degradation is totally
reversed. So
the
results showed the ACE can induce
TRIM21-dependent degradation, is selectivity,
and only enriches with NPC proteins
in proteasome-dependent manner.
And then we want to know when the degradation happens.
We perform the time resolving proteomics in
multiple times after ACE treatments.
As the heat map shows, we can see the inner rings
of NPC subunits degraded early, as
fast as four hours after treatment, and followed
by the outer rings of the NPC complex.
However, the nuclear rings and the nuclear basket remains
unchanged within 12 hours treatment.
So the results showed the degradation is an ordered
and structured process.
In the last, we want to know
where is the TRIM21 recruited. So we use a
proximity proteomics.
The TAP-tag fused to the TRIM21 and traded
with biotin and ACE. So protein proximity to the
TRIM21 can be captured and identified
by the proteomics.
As the volcano plot showed, we can see in the right panel,
several NPC proteins are enriched
after ACE treatment. This result shows
the TRIM21 is recruited to the same complex
identified by the global proteomics.
And importantly, this process is dependent on the
NUP98. Because NUP98 mutant
clones, we can see the ACE can no longer induce the
TRIM21 recruit to the NPC complex.
So this result shows the special links
between TRIM21 recruitment to the degradation
complex. And in this process, NUP98
is a key mediator.
Put all the results together, we proposed
the mechanism behind the degradation.
As the picture shows, ACE can transfer to SACOH
and act as a molecular glue to induce the
TRIM21 recruit to the NPC
complex and direct its proteasome degradation
in NUP98-dependent manner. And
to test whether this mechanism can be
extended, we designed the
TRIM21-BESTpro tag to target the
BRD4.
As picture shows, the CRBM-BESTdb21
acts as the positive control. So we can see it can
degradate the BRD4. But however, the TRIM tag shows a
little activity. However, when we
make the BRD4 from the condensates, we can see that
TRIM21 have efficiently degradation the
BRD4. So this result showed that
TRIM21 is a special E3 ligase, and
the degradation is conditional and depends on the
assembly state of the targets. So it offers the
opportunities to target proteins in multimeric
forms.
In conclusion, and in this study, we
find that the TRIM21 can expand this E3 space
in TBD, and the mechanism is
dependent on the multimeric of target proteins.
As the picture shows, we can see that only the multimeric proteins
can activate the TRIM21 and direct its proteasome
degradation. However, the monomer forms of proteins
cannot activate the TRIM21.
SoThese results suggest some
potential applications to target some
pathologic condensate proteins, higher order assembly
proteins, or even virus proteins.
And in this process, proteomics
helps to choose the
selectivity of substrates.
And in the end, our acknowledgments of the original study
are published in 2024 in Cell. And
thanks to all the collaborators of this study.
And this prediction is only based on proteomics
interaction and framework.
And thanks again to the organizers, and I'm
happy to discuss any questions now.
Great work. I'm curious, how do you tell the direct
target
protein versus the downstream effects from this work?
That's a good question.
She asked about how to distinguish the direct
substrates and the downstream effects.
In this study, we performed the proteomics-based approaches.
And
the
time-resolving proteomics helps to find the early
degradation events, and the proximity strategy help to
find
the proximity to proteins TRIM21.
So the two results help to find
what proteins must be the first
substrates. And however, we also used other methods
such as the
pull-down, western blot, and the banding assay to
demonstrate the interaction between the TRIM21 and the substrates.
And
the in vitro ubiquitination also be performed to
identify that the substrates can be
ubiquitinated after recruited to the TRIM21.
I think these results can help to identify that
this substrate is a direct substrate rather than
other
downstream effects.
Thank you.
Maybe two questions from me.
One, for TRIM21,
I believe upon activation, you get
downstream activation of the NF-kappa B pathway,
through a sort of immune activation naturally when TRIM21 gets
activated. I don't know if you've explored that or not, but I'm just wondering
whether you could imagine a scenario where you might be able to
get TRIM21-mediated sort of glued degradation of a
neo-substrate and spare that sort of NF-kappa B
activation.
Oh, sorry, can you repeat the question? It's too long.
Maybe I can follow up with you afterwards.
But I'm just highlighting that TRIM21 being this sort of
immune surveillance type ligase.
As part of its activation mechanism, it can trigger NF-kappa B
signaling.
NF-kappa B.
Yeah. And whether that
may eventually become a
potential liability for TRIM21 based glues or not.
Oh.
We can follow up, though.
No worries.
Sorry, I don't know.
NF-kappa
B.
Okay, if there's no more questions, thank you again for a
great talk.
So I think that brings us to the conclusion of this session.
I want to thank all the speakers again for really
wonderful presentations and
communicating
really fantastic science that's ongoing in this forum.
I thought it was very informative.
Very excited about what we're seeing in terms of
our drug discovery efforts in these early-stage programs
against
some really
challenging and difficult targets that we've known for some time through
advanced sort of chemistry efforts, as well as novel
types of chemical biology, leveraging
induced proximity mechanisms. But then also, starting to see
some new targets coming into the space, and we heard a little bit about
CIBLE and ARNT, for example. And then, really excited to
see the new sort of delivery type mechanisms we saw,
including with the polysaccharides and the DNA
scaffolding. So really excited to see what comes next and
maybe at 2027 we'll hear that. So thanks so much and have a good rest
of your conference.
Okay.
Good.
That was good. Thank you all. Yeah, really nice.
Thank you.
Last question. I'm actually
Ai Zheng's colleague.
Oh, yeah. You know what I'm talking about?
Yeah.
Okay.
I know who I'm talking about, yeah.
I used to be a postdoc at Alexander Hoffmann's lab.
Okay.
He's a direct colleague of mine.
Yes.
So that's a very good question.
You're fine. I want to ask you a question, just a minute.
Can I ask you one more question?
Yeah. Sorry.
Maybe you first.
No, go ahead. It's okay.
So I wonder, that might be advantage.
So in some situation, you might want activated NF-kappa B.
It could be. Yes.
Yeah, like immunotherapy.
It could be. I'm just saying that there is other context where you may not want to
trigger NF-kappa B.
As long as you go to the right-
Probably some kind of hierarchy here, but at
the same time-
I see. Yeah. I'm just wondering whether it's conceivable that
you might be able to get degradation without NF-kappa B activation.
That's definitely possible.
That would be very interesting. Yeah.
Really nice work.
Thank you very much.
I love proteomics.